le 20 août prochain la maison
d'assistantes maternelles les bambino
fêtera ses un an d'existence quatre
assistantes maternelles se sont
regroupés pour monter cette mam un
nouveau mode de garde pour les jeunes
enfants entre la crèche et l'assistante
maternelle indépendante après presque
une année de fonctionnement
marie-lourdes assistantes maternelles
dresse un premier bilan ça fait boum en
ce mois ci du mois donc bientôt on va
fêter le nom de la main
donc depuis l'ouverture de la mam donc
on a amélioré donc là on peut prendre
des stages est un donc la com
tout à l'heure et la stagiaire sabrina
fait déjà une semaine qu'elle a déjà
commencé
et puis vraiment au niveau de
fonctionnement d'eau qu'on fonctionne à
peu près comme micro crèche 1 donc
effectif il ya douze enfants douze
enfants différents d'âge et aller bébé
moyens et grands
on met en place des activités
des activités ludiques et puis il ya des
sorties des sorties une fois par mois
comme au début ça fait déjà une voire
pervers
après par rapport les autres activités
au fonctionne la poupée comme des
structures
paris sabrina est la première stagiaires
à intégrer la mam les bambines moins
passionné quand les métiers de l'enfance
ce stage lui permet de s'enrichir du
savoir-faire des assistantes maternelles
ben les changes la nourriture la
sécurité des enfants
l'alimentation
les jeux d'activités
plein de choses
j'ai choisi de passer stage dans cette
même parce que je suis
dans la structure de garde d'enfants je
me suis dirigé vers cette structure
quand j'aime beaucoup
être en contact avec les enfants et puis
j'aimerais préparer mon ca paix avec les
faits eux et en profiter aussi si l'ama
me prendre comme ça j'ai espace de jeux
chambres aménagées lieu de réveil des
enfants difficiles
l'épanouissement et l'éveil des enfants
mais aussi les accompagner vers
l'apprentissage et la socialisation
donc le matin à l'ouverture
il ya l'accueil l'accueil des parents et
puis on met en classe des matériels
matériel pour commencer l'activité des
enfants qui commencent à partir de 10
heures donc il y aura une collation
avant une collation c'est enlever tous
les enfants pour une collation une
collation c'est juste pour
apprendre les enfants à manger des
fruits et des légumes c'est pas vraiment
le petit jeune et il prend chez eux nous
on donne une collation une collation
serveurs ses fruits et légumes et puis
pour les bébés c'est du jus d'orange du
d'orange frais et puis activité qui
commence à 10h et puis il ya le repas
parce que le repas on le fait pas sur
sur place leur passé on prend avec un
traiteur donc le trekkeur nous livre ce
repas à 10h45 donc le repas est pris sur
la mam vers 11 heures on the keys après
c'est la sieste la sieste des enfants et
après il ya le réveil et sur le nez il
reste sur le nez c'est jusqu'à ça arrive
jusqu'à 14h30
a priori il ya le goûter où il est et
qu'il commence à 15h après il y aura les
changes des enfants après le départ des
enfants commencent à partir à partir de
15 heures ces maisons offrent les mêmes
conditions d'accueil qu'une crèche avec
des horaires plus souples un cadre
rassurant et sécurisant pour la plus
grande tranquillité des parents